deep within the sacred hollows she howls
with the wolf runs with the deer and
hunts the wild when no humans dare to
pair upon her naked form except for one
whom she turned into his stag and had
her love in pack ran the flesh from his
bones Artemis was one of the most
revered and honored of the ancient Greek
deities her rule spanned across many
things including hunting the moon
virginity childbirth and the wilderness
and wild animals
she was also considered the protector of
young girls up into the age of marriage
she was just one of Zeus's many children
and went by a host of different names
her Roman name diana is one that most
people will be familiar with if we take
a look at the Iliad the goddess is
referred to as Artemis the wildland
mistress of animals and there are those
who believe that Artemis may have even
predated the era of the ancient Greeks
this is something we've discussed before
on the channel when taking a look at the
egyptian goddess Bastet the ancient
greeks drew some interesting parallels
between the two in regards to hunting
and the protection of children but were
the best that was truly an influence
Artemis is always up for debate
Artemis his mother was Leo a Titan
goddess and very early on she became a
favorite of the god Zeus unfortunately
for Leto she fell pregnant of Artemis
and her twin brother Apollo was Zeus was
still married to Hera who of course was
extremely jealous that Leto carried her
husband's children Hera did nothing but
hinder and caused problems for Leto
during her pregnancy she first cost Leto
out from Mount Olympus leaving her to
wander the earth alone anyone who
offered kindness or shelter to Leto
would be punished by Hera
but her Cronus did not stop there Hera
had Leto pursued by the dragon Python
who hunted her endlessly Zeus would
eventually intervene by sending the aid
of a strong wind that would carry Leto
out to sea and eventually help her reach
the island of Delos once Leto had
reached the secluded Island the rest of
the goddesses arrived to help her give
birth but Hera chose to remain on Mount
Olympus and she even tried to detain the
goddess of childbirth ilithyia
but
with the help of iris they were both
able to reach the island Leto first gave
birth to Artemis who was said to offer
her mother assistance with the birth of
her twin brother hence why Artemis was
often associated of childbirth in the
days that followed Apollo was eventually
born the time difference between the two
births does vary in some accounts he was
born the day after his sister and in
others it wasn't until several days
after Leto now face the most impossible
task of raising Artemis and Apollo while
being exiled from the other gods she
would receive no help and the mother and
her two children traveled Elijah in seek
of refuge the influence and fury of Hera
continued to follow Leto and her
children the local villagers even
attempted to stop them drinking from
wells and Springs
and as a result Leto turned them all
into frogs
Artemis and Apollo continued to grow at
an incredible rate and their newfound
skills of a bow meant that they were now
more than capable of defending
themselves as well as their mother when
the dragon Python finally found them
Artemis and Apollo killed the Beast
despite only being days old once Artemis
and Apollo were fully grown they were
only concerned with avenging their
mother and winning back her honor and
place amongst the gods during a ceremony
in the name of Leto the mortal neo be
taunted the goddess claiming that she
was more deserving of a place amongst
the gods because she had given birth to
seven sons and seven daughters the twins
were so incensed by the insult that they
decided the mortal would have to pay for
her hubris Apollo with his poison arrows
struck down her seven sons and Artemis
her seven daughters the punishment may
sound extremely harsh but Artemis and
Apollo had grown up with their mother
being exiled and continuously hunted
their reaction to the insult was a
message to all but they would no longer
tolerate to this kind of disrespect it's
believed that Artemis and Apollo then
traveled all the lands punishing those
who turned away their mother during her
pregnancy the strength and determination
shown by Artemis and Apollo meant that
their mother would once again return to
Zeus's favour despite the protests of
his wife Hera the majority of Leto's
time from then on was spent hunting in
the wilderness with her daughter
throughout the years Artemis has been
depicted as a young woman carrying a
hunting bow and a quiver of arrows often
being accompanied by a deer one of the
many animals she considered sacred
Artemis was quite often admired as a
great Huntress and her skills of a bow
could only be matched by her brother but
despite her love for the hunt Artemis
was an avid protector of the wilderness
and all those that called it home
the animals that were slain by autumn
aswer considered sacred and the hunt was
essentially a ceremony in honor of the
wilderness she would seek vengeance upon
those who were seen to do harm to
animals regardless of who they were the
story of King Agamemnon is a good
example the king had killed one of
Artemis his sacred stags on the hunt and
as a punishment he was told that he
would have to sacrifice his own daughter
when he eventually agreed
Artemis swapped his daughter with a stag
and the King believed in his daughter
had been killed learnt the consequences
of his actions Artemis was able to teach
the King a lesson without the sacrifice
of his daughter who played no part in
her father's crimes showing us that she
is indeed vengeful in her defense of the
wilderness but she's also just an affair
Artemis was known as a virgin goddess
and the gift of chastity is one she
asked to be given by her father Zeus
despite the large amount of potential
lovers that desired the attention of
Artemis she remain devoted to hunting
and nature rejecting all proposals of
love and marriage there were a few
companions who came close to winning the
affections of Artemis but none of them
came as close as the giant hunter Orion
he first saw Artemis on the island of
Crete and the two began hunting together
in time that you eventually would fall
in love and Orien told the goddess that
he would slay every animal in the world
if it would prove his love having heard
what Orion's said the goddess of the
earth Gaia would not let her creations
die and she gave birth to an enormous
scorpion who would eventually kill Orion
naturally the death of Orion called
Artemis great sorrow and she pleaded
with her father Zeus to immortalize the
Fallen Hunter and so a Ryan and the
Scorpion who killed him were given their
own constellations there is a different
version of this story and in that
version Apollo did not like the
relationship between
sister and the hunter Orion when he told
his sister she ignored him as she had
grown fond of the hunter Apollo did not
appreciate his sister's response and in
turn he devised a plan to remove Orion
permanently he challenged his sister to
see whose skills of a beau were superior
when his sister asked what they were
hunting he pointed at a barely visible
figure swimming in the distant lake
knowing that she was more than capable
of proving her brother wrong
Artemis pulled back her bow and fired
Artemis did not realize until it was too
late but it was Orion swimming in the
lake and she had just unknowingly killed
her lover
Artemis as large popularity amongst the
ancient Greeks men that she featured in
a number of myths and stories which
often involved the goddess transform in
individuals into animals one of which
featured the hunter acti on the grandson
of Apollo who found himself on the wrong
side of Artemis is Roth one morning when
walking through the forest he stumbled
across the spring where Artemis and her
nymph companions were bathing he stopped
and began to stare when he was spotted
by the goddess he attempted to apologize
for looking at the goddess while she was
naked
but Artemis interrupted him telling him
if he spoken of a word she would
transform him into a deer act eons
hunting dog soon came running by their
master and as he called to silence them
the goddess had done exactly as she said
and transformed him into a deer he began
to run into the woods being pursued by
his own dogs that would eventually catch
up with him and tear him into pieces
the story of Actium is now thought to
represent the act of human sacrifice in
order to appease the gods the story of
Scipio T's is quite similar to that of
Actium the young boy came across Artemis
in the spring when she was bathing and
as a punishment she transformed him into
a young girl
the story of the alidade Giants is one
when we see Artemis herself transform
into an animal the two drawings marched
from Mount Olympus of the intention of
taking the goddesses as their own
Artemis transformed herself into a deer
and darted in between the two giants as
they attempted to spear the animal they
missed
instead impaling each other in another
version of this story Artemis was
overpowered by the two giants and just
as they were about to impale her her
brother Apollo came to her aid placing a
deer in between them causing the two
giants to once again impale each other
although Artemis may have been
considered as somewhat of a secondary
deity she was still vastly important to
most women as she was looked to when
they needed the protection until they
were ready to marry if you've ever heard
the expression I prefer the company of
animals to humans it's one that
definitely applies to Artemis she spent
very little time amongst mortals and
other gods and when she did it was quite
often followed by tragedy this could
have been a reason why Artemis remained
so devoted to maintaining her virginity
and spent most of her time caring for
animals at times Artemis does appear as
quite a fair and just goddess but she
did not hesitate to kill those who
attempted to wronged her the majority of
those slain by Artemis either
dishonoured her or the wildlife she
cared for Artemis has quickly become one
of my favorite goddesses as she presents
us of an almost perfect mix she's known
to be extremely caring protective and
nurturing but at the same time if she
feels threatened or disrespected her
actions are ruthless and she will have
retribution
a caring and nurturing figure but yet a
warrior Huntress to me autumn s is not
your stereotypical goddess as she
presents traits that we would associate
with both male and female gods his
Artemis our goddess that you can relate
to or do you prefer any of the other
goddesses let me know in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained